moi mon rêve ça c'est préparer les
jouets cassés mon rêve c'est d'être miss
grosse boule d'or je vais faire miss
france ces gars sont alors voilà c'est
ça oui j'ai besoin de ton aide t d croit
bien devenir miss france non je suis
très sérieux d'accord avant le physique
et le mental je me sens plus fort enfin
si vous tombez sur votre cas là l'entrée
est de savoir tenir droite respirer si
ça peut vous aider
je peux avoir une explication y'a pas ma
tasse et des perles etc ou 40 heures je
suis du 42
montrez nous comment vous buvez du vent
québec quelques minimes et où vous
connaissez la distance entre
l'excellence l'ordinaire quelques
millimètres ce n'est pas une vraie femme
et tu ne le saura jamais mais je pense
que tu seras un peu sert de moi mais je
suis fier de toi je suis fier de mes de
toit ou naturels tu lâche rien et tu as
la cérémonie j'aime les enfants les
handicapés femmes en même temps
[Musique]
pourquoi voulez-vous devenir miss france
pour devenir quelqu'un
[Musique]